[Music]
a meat shield
just there to block stuff the most
underappreciated role across the
entirety of the esports landscape
wet noodles going ham yeah we talked
about it you know
and so top lane is in trouble comes up
the depth charge goes down 200 hp eat
the meow
and yet taken too far these characters
are sometimes capable of creating
game breaking metas it's not like i
don't want to
play
like overwatch because i do but the meta
right now
literally is ass
but when used right they can achieve
unforgettable feats of greatness
a bit more time someday he's running in
1v1
and 100d still doing it what is this
what are they doing right now that is
interesting that is a really good over
the roof there
oh my oh
[Applause]
once again bathed in the glory of the
radius
thompson he does not give a crap anna
will give all the life
this is just fountain farming
you got it this is salt breaking
what is the first thing that comes to
mind when you hear the word
tank chances are it's probably something
to do with size
i might as well use it it looks just
gonna run out that's the
biggest size i haven't processed eric
though oh well but you also
probably think of a low-skilled player
who basically uses their character's
body as a target for enemy attacks
a brute who exists solely to absorb
damage for their team kind of like
actual tanks
heavily armored and able to take a ton
of abuse without suffering too many ill
effects
it's not a position that people
generally associate with high stakes
gameplay or
incredible wins so i understand that
people
might look down a bit on tank players
but in the tank category itself there's
definitely a difference between those
who excel at the role
and those who just really don't know
what they're doing in a game like
overwatch the tanks roll usually follows
a pretty traditional route
they're brawny characters with high
health who protect the little guys
they're going to have the nano boost
from jonah we'll see which target he
wants to go for it's very likely gonna
go for the winston
but actually gonna put it on the genji
instead of beautiful hook libero's out
of the fight
what a hook from hotba couldn't have
been better timed
two olds for not he gets them down in
casual mode
it is the least popular role in the game
with some of the shortest queue times
after all it's hard to look cool when
you don't get to do much of the classic
hero stuff lots of players just want to
click heads
but for those in the know the tank roll
has
obvious advantages
and in the owl leaning heavily into
tanks had some
pretty unfortunate consequences in fact
tanks are at least partly responsible
for a meta that nearly
killed the overwatch esports scene goats
as soon as they see the defensive setup
they will just simply swap it away
crucial time lost here
for the outlaws
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm just letting the fans give their uh
the fans here in the studio give their
opinion
well you know you want your team to win
right they're gonna have to play what's
better
and the two to two role lock that was
meant to counteract the damage i think
for me overwatch is like picking random
heroes and doing good with it even
whether it be like a tank of support or
whatever the [ __ ] and then just two two
two lock mate is so like [ __ ] stale
for me
and then banning like here dude that
[ __ ] is so annoying
but in spite of the grief that it
brought to the professional scene
in both the owl and competitive at large
it is a role that is
widely considered to be crucial to a
team's success
tanks are the ones on the front lines
breaking apart fortified positions like
closely grouped enemies and
narrow choke points and the role itself
can be approached from two different
angles
creating space for your team on the
front lines as the main tank
is gonna be eliminated into the back
goes by has custom completely locked in
the room
will be able to think about follows up
for the other supporter kraken
gonna be going down and he is not done
yet just chase is deep
gets absolutely everybody this guy has
been on fire
all weekend long or peeling for your
team as a surprising source of damage
from the sidelines as an
off tank tries to use the ground but
takes it away
that can actually do it comes through
they lock them up right
goes dropping the bomb up over the top
can you get the picks
he absolutely can
in a game that revolves around attacking
and defending these points
using tanks correctly is often the only
way to ensure that your team can push
through
or survive the round in short tanks are
a lot more big brain than people think
that said it does take a certain type of
player to do well
in the role in dota 2 for example there
aren't really any tanks in a traditional
sense
it's not even formally considered a role
instead you have tanky playmakers
who take a lot of hits from magical and
physical sources
relying on a mixture of hp armor and
movement to stay alive have this you've
got the damage to bring down this tide
no tail jerax hammers are all relatively
low they're desperately trying to kill
him yaps was just going to bail on him
and says you're on in on this one on
your own father i've got to leave you
behind jared's trying to move away with
the ghost scepter but look they just
can't kill him
his person is so damn tanky with the
greaves it's taking them an
absolute age to bring him down even with
wrestle beating into him
he just is not dying the plus 24 talon
on the kraken shell block it's
impossible to play against kill him
now that might seem basic but the truth
is a little more complicated
to succeed as a tanky dota hero a player
has to consider their position on the
map
the other heroes on their team and how
that combination will work to execute
either a team fight or tower push
players who do want to give the role a
try have a few
options in game that can help them do
just that and the ones who give it a
shot
are rarely disappointed any time he
feels that he can get him with a rabbit
hill over in fact
they're going to try and fight with the
horn here and straight away and it comes
into the midfield control he has the
rounding
but now they could just run og's heroes
down one by one thompson
tries to double the average but the mech
is pop and thompson are dead
league of legends has had its own share
of overpowered
tankiness to contend with like the 2017
tank meta that saw these immovable
objects
dominate the top lane this is a kid
who's shown up against definitely
many opponents two wet noodles going ham
yeah we talked about it you know
and so top lane is in trouble comes up
the depth charge goes down 200 hp eat
them
to succeed as a tank a player must
possess a certain degree of
masochism you have to be prepared to
sacrifice yourself
for your squishy teammates and while
killing enemies isn't
really the point of having a tank
character on your squad
neither is mindlessly absorbing hit
after hit
yeah i think there are a lot of nuances
to playing a good tank
how you deal out your crowd control
how you know when you actually have to
kite back and not take
unnecessary damage that really makes the
difference between a good tank and a
great tank
whether playing offensively to start
fights or defensively to peel for their
allies
tanks truly shine when they get to
divert the enemy's attention
and remove threats from their teammates
and while that may sound boring
there are certain players out there
who've made the role more fun
we have seen mvp players go for tanks
doing bee is a great example
we've seen him take the likes of scion
and
poppy into the mid lane where the enemy
mid laner simply cannot burst him down
and he has free roam on the map so i
think tanks is definitely a very varied
class
with a lot of different nuances to them
some assassins even abandoned their
one-shotting ways to become
unkillable titans like echo in 2016.
they get [ __ ] as well the hero for dsm
no tracing as well huey he's going to
dodge out of that winter's bite but the
gravity feels down they're going to try
and turn things around
so much healing onto who he actually
takes a bio on the other side as well
going on he's going to take out one more
afro he's going to try and live in
haunted says i don't think so
gets stunned against the wall but he's
going to keep chasing afromoo
oh my god what's up somehow and now he's
dead
and while we are nowhere near an all
tank meta in league right now because of
how important they are to winning team
fights they've almost
always been a staple of competitive play
for the play again
impact of the front line here comes
smoothie going for the knock if they
might catch in yes they do
bio frost is down smooth is going to
trade his life as well though four
versus four
no supports alive no guardian angel for
meteos whereas tsm still have two
and weavers catches up a couple now can
they have the follow-up damage
a couple of stunts come in they've got
bjergsen and they shut up down with a
1600 damage grid
double blow meteos another knockout
trades his life but it's double up gets
the ga
kill take everybody they've got three
impact goes down
and a's for dsm so tanks have an
important role to play in
many games but as with everything
balance
is important ultimately though no matter
what game you play or
how you choose to play it protecting
your teammates
is a noble pursuit sacrificing yourself
for the greater good can be as vital to
lifting that coveted trophy
as any of the flashiest plays out there
[Applause]
i had to
oh god i got andrew
oh let's go zaya let's go ziya let's go
andrew
kidding no one's watching them you saw
that right